so let's talk about the nine most
commonly made mistakes
nearly everyone makes doing Kido okay
number one doing it without in a minute
fasting now the whole purpose of Kido is
to fix insulin to actually lower insulin
the fix in sort of resistance and why
not add in tremendous fasting because
every time you eat you raise insulin so
if you just do ketosis without
intermittent fasting you may not lose
weight especially if you're eating like
six meals a day so it's number one
number two eating when you're not hungry
so it's like if you're not hungry and
you eat what's gonna happen is you're
gonna spike insulin again so here you
were you're sleeping all night you're
burning fat you're not hungry in the
morning yet you eat well your body was
in fat burning all night long so now
it's gonna not be in fat burning because
you just ate so I would not eat unless
you're hungry alright number three
eating too much protein so when you
consume too much protein you can
stimulate insulin as well so in your
mind sometimes if you're working out you
think oh I need more protein but in
reality all you need is between three to
six ounces per meal it's much better to
consume more vegetables a little more
fat than excessive amounts of protein
okay the only exception is if you're
let's here 18 years old and your
metabolism is super high you can get
away with a little bit more okay number
four omitting the vegetables so in this
situation if you don't consume enough
vegetables you're not going to get the
potassium you need to form the protein
on your body parts you're not going to
get the potassium to help regulate the
heart to the muscles because it's a main
electrolyte you need a tremendous amount
of potassium and that comes from
vegetables seven to ten cups of
vegetables every single day you're gonna
have to bite the bullet and do that and
also without vegetables you can't flush
all the fat coming out through the liver
number five focusing too much on the
weight or the keto sticks so a lot of
times when you weigh yourself you're
like wow I'm not losing much weight but
your stomach is shrinking realize that
you're when you're doing this you are
actually converting more of your energy
to making muscle
and you're losing fat but you're
actually building up more muscle and
muscle wings a little bit more so it
might not show up on the scale so don't
sweat it go by your waist to see if your
waist is shrinking and so the same thing
with the keto sticks if you're not in
ketosis it doesn't mean anything because
you could be utilizing ketones ketones
are the byproduct of fat burning okay so
if you're very efficient and you're
burning up all this fat it's not going
to show up in the urine number seven too
much or too little fat so this is the
variable that you need to really pay
attention to because if you have too
much it could overload the gallbladder
and the liver and cause right shoulder
pain if you don't have enough you might
not be able to make it from one meal to
the next so you're gonna be hungry but
as you do this and your system is more
efficient and you're burning more of
your fat you'll need less dietary fat
okay number eight allowing too many
carbohydrates okay now if you really
have a person to a food log and they
start looking at the hidden carbs you're
gonna find that it's like exceeding that
50 gram limit per day I like to keep my
carbs below 30 grams every single day
however you don't have to worry about
calculating the vegetables because we
want you to consume a lot of vegetables
okay number nine worrying about the
cholesterol and this is a big one
because think about it here you are
releasing fat from the fat cells what
does that mean that means you're
releasing triglycerides and cholesterol
so when you do that what do you think is
gonna happen in your blood it's going to
go up so I put a link down below so you
can get the full understanding of what
that means but it's not gonna be a
problem alright thanks for watching hey
thank you so much for watching keep
spreading the word and share this video